hey folks if you'd like to support me or
this channel at muff university in
creating more video tutorials then
please consider making a financial
contribution at my website
moofuniversity.com thanks and enjoy the
video
in this video i really don't want it to
take too long i just want to give you a
little bit of information about
galactolipids and sulfur lipids and give
you an example of how one might look so
from before the membrane lipids we saw
that we had black galactolipids and
sulfolipids that have a glycerol
backbone two fatty acid tails and a
carbohydrate portion and if that
carbohydrate portion has a sulfate group
attached to it it's a sulfur lipid if
not it's a galacto lipid
um
there is a thought that this is the the
most prevalent
most prevalent type of membrane lipid
it's the most abundant and it's found
mostly in plant cells
plant cells
specifically
in the thylakoid membrane
of the thylakoid membranes
of chloroplast
chloroplasts
so how might one of these look
well of course we have the glycerol
backbone and the two fatty acid tails
and then we have to have a carbohydrate
portion so i draw one here
you should if you've studied
carbohydrates you should be able to
recognize
this
sugar
it is
do you want to guess maybe it is
galactose
it is galactose
so hence
hence galacto lipids okay
so this is what a galacto lipid might
look like and if you wanted a sulfur
lipid you would just replace the ch2oh
portion the ch2oh portion which is this
portion up here
right you would replace that
with a sulfate group that would look
like this
so basically instead of ch2oh you'd have
ch2 so3 minus
so that's kind of how a sulfur lipid
would look and how a galacto lipid would
look so i hope that video was helpful at
least somewhat interesting and i'm glad
it was kept brief thanks for watching yo
if you found that video helpful don't
forget to like comment subscribe for
more content and if you know anybody who
might find the videos helpful then
please share with them thanks happy
studying